die drei luca zaia
die 3 lukas
aktiv des vertrauens luca laser hat mal
wieder ermittelt meine brille jetzt weg
eure detektiv vertrauens hat
der meisterdetektiv des jahres hat sich
mal wieder in die weiten des internet
begeben oder lieben freunde und andere
interessante entdeckungen zu dem fall
bibi und julians trennen entdeckt die
trennung von babys beauty palace und
janko ist wirklich die nachricht
schlechthin die gerade unsere
bundesrepublik deutschland in atem hält
ohne unterbrechung wird darüber geredet
in den printmedien in den onlinemedien
alle youtuber äußern sich dazu es wird
in streams behandelt und was machen
julian baby eigentlich
ein magnetischer seifen aufhänger
das ganze internet zerbricht sich gerade
über unsere trennung und meinen
eventuelles fremdgehen mit einem typen
stuttgart und bonn das maul dies ist so
crazy dieser seite aufhänger bei meiner
oma aber gut ich meine wir müssen es ja
auch irgendwie positiv sehen als julian
co das öffentlich gemacht hat vor ein
paar tagen dass die beiden sich getrennt
haben gabi wir halt einfach beim friseur
also wenigstens zeigt sich jetzt heute
nicht ihre haare oder
[Musik]
ja okay ich auch wieder ihre haare
gezeigt während julian com leidet unter
der trennung und während sich das ganze
internet darüber unterhält aber
wenigstens ist sie in deutschland bei
ihrer familie und jetzt nicht wieder in
urlaub
[Musik]
bibi hat also jetzt schon abgeschlossen
mit dieser ganzen sache das ging
natürlich jetzt relativ fix vor einigen
tagen hat sie noch um privatsphäre
gebeten ihrer story was halt irgendwo
keinen sinn ergibt weil die beziehung so
krassen öffentlichkeit stand sie sind
selbst schuld daran wie sie das alles
die öffentlichkeit gezogen haben mit
ihrer familie mit den kindern mit der
ganzen beziehung mit den ganzen post mit
den ganzen beiträgen wenn sie selber
auch die trennung öffentlich machen muss
dass da jeder was sagen wird wenn die
zwei das alles geheim gehalten hätten
dann wäre das jedoch etwas anderes
gewesen diese gerüchte generell diese
tech talks in denen baby mit einem
anderen typen gesichtet wurde die
existieren bereits seit wochen ich habe
dann ein video zu gemacht weil ich mir
dachte erst wenn die sich offiziell zu
äußern kann man sich auch erlauben da
was sozusagen es war genau so wie die
sache mit paid mir damals wo wir in
paris waren und in berlin und dann gab
es das dokr die anderen täter geschickt
und dann kam kickbox mit millionen von
aufrufen und blabla das fand ich nicht
gut weil wir es selber privat halten
wollten da wir in julias allerdings
selber sohn die öffentlichkeit getreten
haben durch die story von julian und so
weiter und so fort ist es natürlich
logisch dass ich da leute darüber
unterhalten deswegen auch an dieser
stelle ganz kurz der appell von mir
bitte hated nicht auch das was ich mache
ist einfach mein humor ich glaub das
willst du ja auch mit dem die drei
drucker zeichen
jedoch sind wieder einige sachen ans
licht gekommen zu denen ich mich äußern
möchte und ich euch natürlich nicht
vorenthalten möchte denn
die detektei luca laser ermittelt wie
vorhin bereits gesagt hat bibi mit der
ganzen sache ein bisschen schneller
abschalten können als julia encke und
das sieht man auch ganz einfach mit
diesem beitrag hier es hat sich vor 17
stunden hochgeladen und sie
präsentiert sich das sehr reizt sind in
einem roten kleid in einem hotelzimmer
wenn wir uns die kommentare mal angucken
sehen wir dass das kleid tatsächlich
absolut niemanden juckt da steht nämlich
nur mach mal lieber statement video mit
20.000 likes wir wollen ein statement
mit 30.000 likes ist nicht ihr ernst mit
17.000 likes immer noch kein statement
mit 12.000 likes you changed mit 20.000
likes sogar nach abstand julian hinter
dir mit 18.000 likes statement mit
12.000 likes ich bin bibi hat sich ganz
schön verändert es solche bilder hat sie
mir gebracht früher mit 14.000 likes ich
glaub ihr könnt recht dass
sie ignoriert
diese ganzen vorwürfe irgendwie weg aber
es klappt halt nicht so richtig durango
hat übrigens seit der veröffentlichung
der trennung in seiner instagram story
keine weiteren beiträge hochgeladen hat
sich auch sonst nicht groß geäußert
außer dass er eine fragerunde in seiner
story gemacht hat und das möchte ich
euch natürlich auch nicht vorenthalten
denn auch unter meinem video was sich
vorgestern zu der ganzen trennung hier
hochgeladen habe haben leute geschrieben
ich hoffe so sehr das ist ein experiment
ist überlegt mal angenommen die beiden
bemerkten dass sie nicht mehr so
trennten wie früher und überlegen sich
eine strategie wieder aufmerksamkeit zu
bekommen dann wäre eine vorgespielte
trennung das krasseste sie könnten sich
den plan überlegt haben und alles so
eingefädelt haben und dann in so einem
monat hatte da sind sie wieder viele und
damit meine ich wirklich extrem viele
leute haben dieses gerücht gestreut das
ist alles nur ein experiment ist ich
habe selber untermain wie du diesen
kommentar hier geschrieben wo ich gesagt
habe dass ich mir das nicht vorstellen
kann und auch dass julian mittlerweile
selbst das habe ich dann über einen
nachtrag eingefügt schon gepostet hat
dass es kein experiment ist das hier ist
ein screenshot aus seiner story daher
fragen beantwortet und auf die frage
viele sagen das ist ein experiment ist
dass du das auch fans erzählt hast
stimmt das hat er geantwortet nein so
etwas würde ich niemals machen damit man
man keinen spaß die nachrichten nicht
angeblich versendet habe sind auch alle
fake das hätte ich höre mich kann allem
die nachrichtensprecher
ich geh zur tagesschau auf das ist aber
auch eigentlich ehrlich gesagt wirklich
logisch gewesen also klar bibi hat schon
oft schwachsinn gebaut mit dem rock pop
lied und mit ihnen mit dem xxl kondom
videos in der badewanne und keine ahnung
was aber dass die ihre komplette
kreativität so aufs spiel setzen ist
einfach nur unvorstellbar gewesen da
fliegt eine fliege von meiner der
bastard allerdings auch einige und habe
ein video vorgestern geschrieben das
trikot vielleicht hätte fremdgegangen
sein können als erstes weil diese bilder
aufgetaucht sind wie janko im nachtflug
also einem kölner club miteinander mädel
gesehen wurde der mann dann po gefasst
hat daraufhin hat julian allerdings dass
hier geschrieben die bilder mit der
unbekannten frau im club sind nach der
trennung entstanden doch noch mal
geschrieben dass jeder anders in
bestimmten situationen damit umgeht da
frage ich mich allerdings nur seit wann
sind sie denn getrennt
also das ist ja das interessante die
haben ja diesen podcast zusammen wo sie
noch vor einigen folgen gesagt am ende
sind zusammen stellt euch mal vor wir
wären nicht mehr zusammen bleibt wenn
diese sache im nachtzug allerdings
gewesen war dann müsste das ja auch
schon ein bisschen länger her sein dann
war es wiederum so das baby ja
allerdings auch schon vor wochen
entdeckt wurde beim rumknutschen das
heißt selbst wenn ich schon länger
getrennt sein sollten haben sie das herr
geheim gehalten die leute verarscht es
gibt verschiedene theorien die gerade
umgehen und mich juckt es eigentlich
auch alles nicht so richtig und genau
deswegen werde ich das video an dieser
stelle jetzt auch beenden meine lieben
freunde denn ich wollte dieses video
eigentlich nur ganz kurz dafür nutzen
und euch damit zeigen es ist kein
experiment und auch wenn da bilder
gesehen wurden von nun an mit einem
anderen medium club und auch wenn es
auch neue bilder gab von baby mit ihrem
typen tennessee amrum turteln geht es
den beiden verhältnismäßig anscheinend
ganz gut bibi hat ihre neuen haare
fliegt den urlaub julian lenkt sich auch
ab
die sachen die beiden sich nicht einfach
mal eine kamera gesetzt ein youtube
video gemacht sowie david optik mit
leiser coach damals
blieb auch noch geld verdienen sondern
hätten die zwei einfach vernünftig sagen
können wir sind seit dann und dann
getrennt die kinder stehen an erster
stelle
es gibt bilder videos screenshots ihr
umgehen und das meiste davon ist fake
vertraut uns unserer fakten wir brauchen
jetzt unsere ruhe ende
sich natürlich auch alle leute
unterhalten weil dies selbst so krassen
die öffentlichkeit gezogen haben ich
meine jeder post auf instagram von den
beiden war irgendwie zusammen mit liebe
verbunden und kooperation zusammen und
da wollen ferien aus dass gefühlt die
frage die ich am eis und aber im video
gelesen wer fragt sich auch was jetzt
wohl aus dem gemeinsamen haus wird leute
die gegner sind scheißegal was ist mit
dem haus auf malle kurz danach trat er
aus dem schnitt im juli
nicht einigen können mit dem ferienhaus
ich würde zu nehmen was ich allerdings
wirklich extrem schwierig fanden waren
diese ganzen kommentare und diese fake
screenshots in die richtung dass julian
jetzt irgendwie selbst anderen fan
schreibt das ist
und dass da leute das sich aus aller
welt sie bewegen haben eine podcast
gesagt was immer dann wenn wir das mal
sagen würden dass wir uns trennen aber
als dann doch nicht machen und dann hat
die julia doch wenige sagt das werden
die sich trennen denn die hälfte der
handtaschen von bibi haben will und dann
haben die leute auch bei mir die
kommentare gestehen dass ich total sie
finden dass sie das als privat ist kein
break ich habe da wie im video
vorgestern schon zugesagt auch mit
sandra darüber gewettet dass wenn das
ein trend ist muss ich
fallschirmspringen wenn es kein bringt
es muss andere marathon laufen sandra
hersteller viele voll allerdings können
wir jetzt wirklich nur abwarten es
bleibt natürlich spannend in der ganzen
situation baby und julian vor allem wenn
noch weitere videos screenshots von
irgendwelchen sachen raus kommen in
nächster zeit allerdings will ich an der
stelle erst mal sagen die drei luca
zeichnen detektei luca laser hat
ermittelt wir haben herausgefunden ist
es kein experiment und wir sehen uns
hoffentlich nie wieder auf diesem kanal
im ein content ist komplett scheiße
[Applaus]